kind of [ __ ] sucks dude that's rough
so you can abandon your kids and cash in
later
that's good yeah yeah that's why you
have kids that's my retirement plan yeah
I should have [ __ ] gave birth to
[ __ ] tiger in China
[Music]
all right so there's this there's this
woman she's 29 year old uh her name is
Zhang she's from Guangzhou in southern
China and she was abandoned by her
biological parents when she was two
years old
and has no relationship with them
whatsoever oh damn
reportedly abandoned as her biological
parents could not financially support
her oh I want you but I cannot appall
you and they rarely contacted her
throughout her entire life no mobile
phone never a guy there's always a woman
it's usually a woman it's usually a
woman but they're more cuter though
that's what I'm saying when you have
like a cute little boy and a cute little
girl like
how can you even get rid of any but then
if you had to choose boy sometimes
easier yeah but then they think about
but maybe the girl cries too much so
even though they're cute you're like
too loud
well I'm you know obviously in the
traditional Chinese culture the the boy
will carry on the family name so the
boys make more money in Game of Thrones
culture as well
um so Zhang was raised by her father's
sister and consider her consider her
aunt family uh her aunt's family to be
her biological oh so she got abandoned
into her family member so is her real
abandonment yeah dude yeah that's a
lateral move that's a lateral move I
just switching departments in the same
company yeah and she didn't build too
much emotional she wasn't marketing now
she's in HR
good they're both equally important you
got the same 401K yeah dude she might
have got a better deal it might have
been a better fit yeah she went from
[ __ ] Sony to Samsung she's still in
Sony she switched check stance yeah yeah
dude so when when Zang recently used her
obviously she's now 29 years old good
for her so one day recently used her
savings to buy her cousin an apartment
wow damn she used her her savings about
her cousin who wishes how nice which was
her aunt's kid so treats them like a
sibling well like a brother or a sister
they wouldn't do that
her biological parents reappeared in her
life all of a sudden he said actually
can I get one too and reportedly
demanded that she buy her biological
brother that they kept in apartment as
well so like they're like surprise why
would I buy my cousin a house dude
that's a gigantic [ __ ] you man so it
seems right and the traditional Italian
speak how about these [ __ ] nuts bite
these nuts in apartment huh
well unfortunately we all know that
things are a little bit more complicated
okay no we don't simplify this [ __ ] the
world is black and white yeah this is
simple dude there's no Brown and Asian
just all black and white people can we
appear to tear while you're ready
after Zing refused her estranged parents
filed a lawsuit against her for 500 000
yuan in Parental maintenance you could
do that so they've been paying parental
maintenance can do that the Court ruled
that although Zhang is not obligated to
buy her brother an apartment because
that's baloney good she must negotiate
the amount with her parents and pay the
parental maintenance fee what the [ __ ]
is that under the civil code of China
adult children have a legal obligation
to support their parents regardless of
estrangement or abandonment ooh China
damn that's the law regardless of
Abandonment you said this is Taiwan this
is China China [ __ ] sucks dude that's
rough what is the obligation the
obligation so you can abandon your kids
and cash in later
that's good
that's why you have kids that's my
retirement plan yeah I should have
[ __ ] gave birth to [ __ ] tiger in
China I'm gonna be a Chinese citizen you
could just have a bunch of abandoned
kids there's [ __ ] Investments dude
that means that Chinese athletes out
there are [ __ ] crushing it because
they're like I don't have to pay child
support and then at the end they're like
my retirement is coming soon under the
civil code just repeated the civil code
of China adult children children have a
legal obligation to support their
parents regardless of estrangement or
abandonment okay so support your support
in general yeah okay well you know this
probably also came in a similar time
frame as like China's like one child
rule so it's not like people were just
pumping out kids knowing that if I
abandoned like 10 of them they're gonna
support me legally so that grandfathered
into the age of having multiple kids
assume that I'm just saying in terms of
the entirety of like the perspective of
things like it was bunked around the
same true that's a good point yeah
um but still that that is a very very
unique thing that we as Asian Americans
look at and are like holy [ __ ] like
getting abandoned and that's that's a
lifetime thing like you have to support
your parents like she's got to kill her
parents dude because that morality is
based on culture how we're supposed to
basically be our parents retirement plan
but to me it doesn't make sense if you
are abandoned yeah because the whole
concept is you've been taken care of
yeah so then now you're giving back now
give back to those who helped you
but then if they haven't fulfilled the
first part of the contract why do you
have to [ __ ] fulfill the last part my
parents fulfilled the first part I still
don't want to take care of them
that's why we live in USA baby yeah
[Laughter]
I wonder
how like if they could take this to
court and then they're like your honor I
present to you case one they didn't do
jack [ __ ]
and they're like so this is how much I
owe jack [ __ ] and then the China Chinese
judge goes granted
but defense attorneys or the plaintiff
is like no they didn't they did do [ __ ]
they made you and then they lateral
moved you over to my sister the Auntie
so you had an upbringing because they
were being responsible in knowing that
they couldn't take care of you that's
what the defense or the [ __ ] uh
Prosecutor's first line would be Define
abandonment oh but then it's like okay
if you're gonna force your uh strange
daughter to pay up what about your bum
ass biological son yeah why the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] yeah maybe they ends up
batting him so he could be a little more
free yeah and they kept him thinking
that he was going to be the breadwinner
but why does he need an apartment he's a
little bugs when he's a loser ass B he's
a loser she did it on purpose just to be
like I'm gonna buy you a thing but not
the parents oh to say [ __ ] you oh so
that that triggered them is a gangster
[ __ ] you like it could be it for sure
for the sake of spiding your uh for sure
do that that should hurt you know it's
kind of cool though like a silver lining
thing is that they it's not gender
biased that they think only the men are
gonna grow up to make money so the law
applies to the women as well that's kind
of cool that is cool yeah why not by
Design yeah
I didn't mean to do it but I did it
I just forgot all this applies to the
lawmaker he's like yeah that's what I
meant I love even in China they're
Italian I mean obviously
weibo users uh Chinese social media
users Express outrage at the Court's
verdict
um people are saying like quote no
support but asking for support really
unacceptable other people saying don't
you feel guilty for not picking up your
daughter or raising her you should
compensate your daughter for uh for a
sweet yeah you [ __ ] face they and they
had to leave her for like the rest of
her life they couldn't come back in like
two years or something they can Circle
back I mean they're relatives right like
they don't even visit each other like
the [ __ ] is that sister it's just a
weird family yeah they're odd up do they
live really far away like I need to know
more of this story and then to come in
specifically only when a house is bought
for the cousin therefore it's like well
you gotta buy one hey but yo if that's
families that's [ __ ] true to life
like you know when like a family member
dies and all of a sudden people come out
of the woodwork that never bothered you
ever and now they're like yo I need a
cut I need a cut and you see the darkest
side of your family I'm so [ __ ] glad
that we weeded out all the [ __ ] faces of
our families yeah [ __ ] happens man yeah
because
I kind of want that I kind of want that
because I imagine myself saying [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you yeah or like leaving a petty
will where it's like where it's like no
you don't get [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
can't do that because I love I really
love yeah the family members that I have
remaining they're [ __ ] amazing so I'm
wishing that one can be a little [ __ ] so
I could like attack them but I can't
because they're all cool such struggles
don't you hate when Japanese family
members are so cool don't you hate it
when you have like this loving
constructive group of people that just
don't give you that [ __ ] that other
families do yeah dude but that's that is
a truth it uh yeah it does it does
happen though you could put that in your
will where you're like this nephew only
gets this much from me if he crashes his
car into this nephew's house and then
this nephew only gets this much money
from me if he crashes his car into that
that's cool have a really creative
stipulation so then now they have to
crash each other and create drama yeah I
like that she sounds really fun that's a
cool TV show it's like six hours but
instead it's like reading of Wills that
have the zaniest requirements
that would be tight yeah I have I bet
you're gonna have some [ __ ] huh I have
people in my family that are that are
gonna control my account that least want
it that are the most honorable and they
are not motivated by money so those are
the people that are chosen to do it that
just so happened to be financially smart
but unmotivated by money that's who are
these people my nephews wow they are
samuraised man yeah yeah dude they're
semi code until you die and then they're
ninjas dude and then they're ninjas
they're like how's your niece all along
[Laughter]
the black face
leave it leave it in
foreign
[Music]